Що спільного між жуйкою, сіллю
та гелем для душу?
Усе це містить пластик.
Пластик всюдисущий.
Маю на увазі, що він справді повсюди.
Пластик у матраці, на якому ми спимо,
у смартфоні, який нас будить вранці,
яке ми одягаємо, в ізоляції вікон, які нас гріють…
Одним словом - всюди!
Навіть буцімто альтернативи пластику
вводять нас в оману - отакої!
Паперові одноразові тарілки часто мають покриття з пластику,
аби папір не розмокав від води.
Консервні банки всередині часто мають
покриття з пластику проти іржі.
Також фільтри від цигарок - один з найпоширеніших видів шкідливого сміття -
значною мірою складаються з пластику.
Але чому пластик такий всюдисущий?
Адже ще кілька десятиліть тому людство обходилося без пластику.
Виробництво пластику вибухнуло у 1990 роки
і відтоді невпинно зростає.
Тому що пластик - це дешево.
А ще цей матеріал практичний, витривалий і легкий.
Я справді аж ніяк не прихильниця пластику.
Але саме цей матеріал уможливив для нас сучасне життя, яким ми його знаємо.
До того ж, це має економічний сенс.
Як постійно наголошують фірми, що виготовляють пластик:
одноразові пластикові упаковки продовжують життя нашим продуктам.
Вони також роблять їх легшими,
а отже й дешевшими у транспортуванні.
Сучасні автомобілі наполовину складаються з пластику.
Це робить їх економнішими.
А будівельна галузь? Тут використовується приблизно 16%  пластику у світі.
Тому що цей матеріал - дешевий і міцний.
Але всі якості, які роблять пластик таким практичним,
роблять його також і шкідливим для довкілля,
причому з катастрофічними  наслідками.
Науковці підрахували, що лише 9% пластику,
який виготовляється у світі,
іде на вторинну переробку.
12% спалюються.
А решта 79% лежить на звалищах або в довкіллі.
Ми настільки звикли до практичності пластику
і до того, що він повсюди,
що споживачам і підприємствам
складно уявити по-іншому.
Деякі альтернативи вже є.
Можна, приміром, замінити предмети зубної гігієни на такі зубоочисні пігулки.
Але ж не можна замінити ВСЕ! Принаймні поки що.
Є спроби припинити цю пластикову залежність.
Приміром, заборона ЄС на одноразовий пластик,
яка вступить у силу з 2021 року.
Але це вирішить лише дуже незначну
частину проблеми.
У короткостроковій перспективі для фірм і таких простих споживачів,
як я, пластик - це найпростіше і найзручніше рішення.
Якщо не буде всеохоплюючої заборони на пластик
або не знайдуть дешевих
практичних альтернатив пластику,
людство залишатиметься пластикозалежним.
ому що пластик, на жаль, дуже практичний.
Але, як і інші залежності, в довгостроковій перспективі пластик знищить саме те,
що є для нас життєво важливим - наше довкілля.